i want to invite you over for dinner at
my house
when you walk in
their chairs scram everywhere smells
delicious you hear people laughing you
see friends hugging and telling stories
there are more than 20 of us here
tonight
teachers tech leaders lawyers moms
it's loud
and it's chaotic
but even if this is your first time
it feels like home
and then we'll sit down to work because
tonight is not a regular dinner
tonight is a culmination of months of
conversations and learning in my living
room
at the end of this night
thirty thousand dollars will go out to a
local grassroots non-profit that is
doing amazing work in our community
and that money
came from everyone in the room
and the decision of where that bond is
going
included all of her voices
this
is a given circle
a group of people with shared values
that comes together to create change
my giving circle the peninsula latina
giving circle is what i know
philanthropy to be
it's joyful
and transformative and collaborative and
intentional
most people don't see us as
philanthropists or this process when
they think of philanthropy but i'm here
to show you the powerful possibility
that exists in all of us to be
philanthropists no matter your age or
your wealth no matter where you live or
where you come from
i am originally from mexico city
moved to the u.s 25 years ago
and in 2007 when i started my first
giving circle i didn't even know the
concept had a name this is not new
collective giving has been going on for
centuries
just in the past two decades
thousands of giving circles got started
all over the world
collectively giving more than 1.3
billion dollars
thanks
i have dedicated my life to this work
and now i lead an organization called
philanthropy together to democratize and
diversify the power of philanthropy
through the power of giving circles
they're given circles with five members
or five hundred each person giving five
dollars or two hundred and fifty
thousand
including any generation identity or
geography
we give to nonprofits
we give it to individuals or to new
projects just getting off the ground
they're women's giving circles and black
given circles
jewish
muslim and interfaith
giving circles that focus on climate
change and civic engagement
cross class and cross race giving
circles
asian pacific islanders and latinx lgbtq
giving circles inside companies
and
social clubs and virtual they're giving
circles in malawi
and china and germany
so these groups keep getting together
year over year because collective giving
is powerful
we can have a much bigger impact
together that we can alone
so
what is the secret
i'm here to show you the four steps to
start a thriving giving circle
the first step is to create belongings
the concept of people banding together
to create change is as old as humanity
itself
and collective giving has roots in
cultures all around the world
but today
we don't even talk to our neighbors
anymore
but by belonging to something that is
bigger than ourselves and the collective
power of our dreams and voices
that is what create creates that lasting
commitment to each other and to change
now given circle you start with a group
friends neighbors colleagues
and you take the time to deepen those
relationships
those folks back in my living room we
basically started as strangers
but because we ate together and laughed
together and shared stories
and decided on our set share the values
we ended up creating a lasting community
that
gets together year over year
giving circles make you feel at home
the second step is to
hold space for this course
it can be completely completely
overwhelming to know how to make an
impact as an individual but in a given
circle you have the opportunity to learn
together
thousands of people engaging in
challenging conversations
getting new perspectives about the
issues in their communities
we work across differences and
ideologies and viewpoints but because
everyone has an equal voice we always
walk in with something to share and walk
away with something learned
i'm back in my living room we're
tackling the hardest part
to decide where are we getting together
so
we'll learn and then we'll vote and
we'll discuss and we'll change our minds
and then we'll change our minds again
but beyond fail we always come to an
agreement at the end
because we come with an open heart and
an open mind
in a given circle it's not about me or
you
it's about us
together
and once we have shared and discussed
the third step is to give with trust
because in a given circle we give all
together to a shared pot of funding
before even knowing what that where that
money is going to go
we trust each other and that trust
extends to the groups that we're funding
tonight
we're deciding to give to a small
non-profit with a tiny tiny budget
these numbers may shock you
but in the us
88 percent of funding goes to just the
top five percent of nonprofits
and groups led by black and latino
leaders
get far less funding than similar groups
led by white leaders
in my giving circle
we give as you would to a loved one
looking them in the eyes
and unlike most of traditional
philanthropy we give with no strings
attached
literally shifting the power
into the hands of the leaders on the
ground
so they can decide how to best use the
money
because community knows what community
needs for any philanthropist it should
never be about parachuting into a
community to save it
just acting
in partnership
they don't need to be saved
they need to be trusted
and the last step
is just to act in abundance
when people think of philanthropy
they usually just think on big money
and of course you know money is a big
part of a given circle too
because of the multiplying effect my
hundred dollars can turn into ten
thousand or a hundred thousand
you know i even can make my kids look
outside of their phones for two minutes
and pay attention when i'm telling them
that i just gave 50 000
but
philanthropy literally is
love of humanity
giving with an abundance of heart and of
spirit
we can all be
radically generous in so many ways
beyond just money
so after tonight
we all
are going to go and volunteer and
advocate and open doors and sharing
social media
we call this in giving circles giving
your five teeth
time
talent
treasure
testimony and ties
one of my favorite stories of abundance
is that of martin vargas vega
the son of migrant farm workers whose
dream was to become a coder
martingo got trained by a
small tech skills non-profit in his
community
that nonprofit was supported by the
latinos in tech giving circle and for
martin it was incredibly powerful to see
a group of people that looked like him
supporting and fueling the work of the
non-profit that was training him
so after his training
martin
landed this high-profile internship in
silicon valley and the very first thing
he did
was given 50
half of his signing bonus to that
nonprofit
and wait
and the other half
to join the latinos in check giving
circle because he is a philanthropist
martinez
thank you martin is actively using his
voice and his power
to bring more stem programs for kids
that look like him
that is
abundance life-changing things happen
when we look at philanthropy beyond the
money because all the money in the world
is not going to save us but beloved
communities will
for a long time
philanthropy has been just a selected
few
few select
that decide on the impact on many
who should and should again funding what
is and what is not considered impactful
again in the u.s
communities of color receive eight
percent of philanthropy
for women and girls issues
is just
1.9 percent
not even one-third
of one percent
goes to the lgbtq community
we have to change that
when we shift the power of philanthropy
into all of our voices
we change who gives
how we give and ultimately what gets
funded
given by for and with the communities we
represent is the future of philanthropy
and each and every one of us
belong in this movement
just
just think
what if every town
every issue every community
have a given circle with passionate
philanthropies like you
so if you're looking for impact
and connection
and purpose
and joy
join or start a giving circle
no matter if you have five dollars to
give or 50 million
no matter if you are a teacher or a tech
leader or a lawyer or a mom
and if you do have millions
or billions to give
join us in this movement
match a hundred fold or invest alongside
the local giving circle
thank you so much for coming to my
giving circle tonight
in a world that feels heavy
doing philanthropy together fills me
with so much joy and hope for the future
maybe when we started
you thought you were only coming for
dinner
but actually
you just got an invitation to change the
world
let's meet at your house next time
[Applause]